I heard there was a story during the
rounds in The Brady household
this one it's moles star which I know
you've been reading to your new baby son
I decided to have a look at this Brady
and to see if it's sort of if it was
appropriate that's how we say so um yeah
I thought should we have a look so it's
basically about a mole who looks up at
the stars and decides to sort of
basically take them all and put him in
his borrow which I'm not really sure
about this so so let's just let's just
start reading it shall we so I'll read
it like jacanori right so moles Star by
Britta Tekken truck mole lived deep onto
the ground he loved his Cozy home of
burrows dens and tunnels but sometimes
he felt a little lonely in the dark
every night mold popped his head out of
his molehill to say hello to the Stars
he sat on his favorite Rock gazing at
the beautiful twinkling lights in the
sky one night as mold sat on his Rock he
saw a dazzling shooting star and quickly
closed his eyes to make a wish we've all
done that right actually I haven't
because I've never seen a shooting star
but that's another story I wish I could
own all the stars in the world he
whispered
so let's think about this so what can
mole actually see so these stars that
he's claiming to wants what can he
actually see well I think moles are
pretty blind so I'm not sure if you can
see any stars uh so maybe he's talking
about all the stars by last estimate the
number of stars in the observable
universe is about
200 billion trillion Stars roughly about
100 billion in each Galaxy 100 billion
to 400 billion in each Galaxy and
there's about 2 trillion galaxies okay
so that's a lot right that's a lot I
think that's too many I think that's
greedy what I think we should focus on
is the moles actually after roughly the
number of stars that are typical human
or any creature on earth can see there's
about 5 000 of those so typically a
human if say you can see up to what we
call the brightness of the star that
goes up to about magnitude six and
that's about roughly about as far as
humans can see maybe a little bit
further but but that's that's roughly
about this sort of dimis star that we
can see and it's about 5 000 of those
that are visible on Earth okay so that's
probably I've got a little database of
them here actually it's a database of
the brightest stars in in the sky you
know things like the Yale bright star
catalog but there's a few others in
there as well and this includes all the
stars that we can definitely see Usual
Suspects in there like Sirius for
example where else is there we've got
Vega which is you know very bright star
wriggle here I think that's that's one
of the the nearby ones right in Alpha
Centauri so you know so these I say
Beetlejuice there it's Beetlejuice there
yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah so
we've got The Usual Suspects but a whole
bunch of others as well I filtered this
to just only consider those whose
magnitude is six or less and so that's
the brightest ones that humans can
definitely see as I said if you've got a
particularly good eye you might see a
few more but let's not worry about them
because we know mold doesn't have a good
eye okay well once all the stars okay so
where mole opened his eyes he couldn't
believe what he saw there were ladders
all around him leading up to the sky
so these ladies well these so these
ladders if you look at the picture Brady
these ladders are going up to all the
stars so I'll try to figure Okay so
we've got all these ladders and they're
going up to all the stars that the MOG
that we're saying these 5 000 stars that
we're gonna at least humans can see okay
right so I looked at my database and I
sort of said well okay
how you know how how how far are these
Stars away how much ladder do I need
Okay so this database includes the
distances to to all those stars that
we're talking about all those five
thousand or so stars and the total
distance in light years that you would
need of ladders to reach these Stars
it's about 786 million light years it's
quite a lot of ladder right I decided to
think okay can actually can we make
these ladders these ladders which are
going up to all the stars right can we
make them all so I thought okay what
should we make out of well we're gonna
need something light I think so I said
let's go for bottle sword okay so balsa
wood has a density of about 0.1 gram per
centimeter cubed ejection you can get
balsawood down to about a diameter of
about 0.2 centimeters you know your your
sort of rods of bolster if you put all
that together and you try to build your
ladders yeah with rungs you know sort of
every so often then typically I think
you're going to need about
ten thousand billion billion kilograms
worth of leather actually the exact
number is about 9.9 times 10 to the 21
kilograms now that sounds like a lot
right it sounds like a lot of balsa wood
right that you need to make these
ladders and they think in no way mole's
going to do this but actually this is
about that this is this is a lot less
than the mass of the Earth there's about
a thousand times less than the mass of
the Earth the mass of the earth is about
six times ten to the 24 kilograms so so
roughly about six million billion
billion kilograms so it's about a
thousand times more than than this this
the weight of these ladders so lad is
going to the 5 000 or so Stars we can
see
if they're quite flimsy and made of Bowl
sword yeah weigh much less than the
earth yep I couldn't believe it I was
really surprised by it it's really
surprised by it so I thought could you
double check that I've double checked
there's my code Brady it's a double
check triple check then where's the
ladders total ladder Heights here we go
yeah I mean it's just the mass of the
earth is Big this is what it is the mass
of the earth is really big I think that
that's the bottom line it's the mass of
the Earth that's big
is small on the cosmic scale it's a
speck of dust we forever here and these
ladders are quite flimsy not very
compact you know they're just flimsy
ladders that go and then we've got this
this huge whole earth that's roughly
spherical which is a really efficient
way to store stuff in terms of volume I
was really surprised I was really
surprised I agree I actually told Renata
about this my wife right I said she she
was like really she goes is there enough
carbon that's a good question so I found
there's something called The Deep carbon
Observatory which basically you know
they're worried about how much carbon
there is and they've done an estimate
for how much carbon there is on Earth
well it's not quite enough it's not it's
not that far short but it's not quite
enough it's about 1.85 times 10 to the
21 kilograms so that's
1850 billion billion kilograms of carbon
on Earth and in the earth so there's not
quite enough is that assuming both
swords just made of carbon yes it is
right yeah so I mean most most of all
foods is Balsa was actually empty space
especially just just air but actually
the heaviest and what's giving bolster
with its weight is probably mostly
carbon so yeah I mean there's just not
there's not enough Carbon on Earth but
no it's not that far short it's about
you know roughly of what's that factor
of maybe maybe five just under five
different it's just not quite enough
it's annoying so mole you can't make
this out of bowls unless you're going to
start going off to other planets to
collect your bowls of wood you're not
you're not going off on it says okay
let's make it out of carbon fiber so
we're going to make these ladders out of
carbon fiber now
carbon fiber is actually more dense than
Balsa would but of course it can be a
lot thinner okay so it's about two grams
per centimeter cubed is its density but
you can get the diameter of strand you
know of carbon fibers down to about a
thousandth of a centimeter so you can
get it you can get a lot thinner okay
now we're not going to worry about where
the metal could actually climb this at
this stage but we can get much thinner
ladders okay and we can try and rebuild
so how how much is ladders made out of
really thin carbon fiber is going away
well I reckon it's going to be about 3.5
times 10 to the 18 kilograms 3.5 million
trillion kilograms now that's way less
than the mass of the Earth and actually
it's less than the mass of carbon on
Earth so there's enough Carbon on Earth
to make these these carbon fibers
but there's a catch
okay so we could in principle on Earth
make these carbon fiber ladders go into
all the stars
right that we can see
but the problem is there's not enough
surface carbon
okay so the amount of surface carbon
according to this this again this this
deep carbon Observatory is about
4.35 times 10 to the 16 kilograms so
that's 43 000 trillion kilograms that's
the amount of surface carbon so the
carbon in the air the carbon in the land
the carbon in the oceans okay so there's
not enough of that to make your carbon
fibers fiber ladders
to make your carbon fibril ladies you're
going to have to get deep into the Earth
right into the Earth's core and start
getting the carbon out of that and okay
that's gonna be tricky but in principle
if mole can do it he can make us carbon
fiber ladders go into all the stars okay
okay
on job done what does mole do next mold
didn't think twice okay he scurried up
and down the ladders
collecting the Stars one by one and
carrying them home okay mole now we need
to think about this right so mole is now
running up and down these ladders of
which we need to remind ourselves they
are in total 786 million light years
High how long is this is this going to
take him I feel like it's gonna be quite
a long time Brady
all right so I looked it up so how fast
do moles travel
they travel at about six kilometers per
hour
so given he's got to go up and down the
ladders right and let's suppose he's
doing it at six kilometers an hour which
maybe that's a bit of a you know a being
a bit generous because frankly he's
going up right so but okay we'll we'll
do we'll use that number it's going to
take him Brady 280
000 trillion years so that's 2.8 times
10 to the 17 years that's a long time
that's a very long time that's much
longer than the age of the universe it's
certainly longer than the lifetime of a
star right so the star it's our lives
for about 10 billion years this is way
longer than that so I don't think this
is practical for mold to be doing this
this way right he's going to get to
these stars and they'll all be dead so
what's the point right
so I think mole has to find another way
to travel
so I looked at it so I said okay maybe
you could travel on like let's say the
Apollo 10 spacecraft very fast on the
fastest spaces that goes about just
under 40 000 kilometers per hour if you
molded it using the Apollo 10 spacecraft
it would take him about 43 trillion
years that's still not enough stars are
all still going to be dead so then I
went okay what's the fastest spacecraft
we've ever made not necessarily crude or
mold that's the Juno spacecraft okay
that can go at 365
000 kilometers per hour which I frankly
think is amazing but that's still gonna
take you it'll take mole 4.6 trillion
years to do this journey it's just way
too long all the stars are going to be
dead well not all of them we might get
to the first couple but that's you know
it's just it's it's it's no good okay he
needs to do something beyond the
technology we have available right so
he's gonna have to start going close to
the speed of light this is just no
choice in the matter a crunch the
numbers on this a little bit to say
about how fast is it going to have to go
to get to these stars in his lifetime so
moles can live between roughly three
three to six years six years if they're
lucky but they normally crock it around
three okay
so here's what I figured out so if mole
travels within one billionth of a
billionth of the speed of light it's
really really close to the speed of
light within one billionth of a
billionth of the speed of light he will
be able to go up and collect all the
stars in around two years four months
traveling at like 0.999 yeah speed alert
within one billionth of a billionth of
the speed of light just shy of it about
that fraction so you might say well how
does how does that make any sense this
is you've got to do 786
um million light years
okay so this this is where relativity
comes in and starts helping us and helps
or helps them all actually so we're
waiting for more he's going to collect
these stars now for him to collect all
those Stars 786 million light is there
786 million light years back in total
it's going to take him about 1.6 billion
years as far as work in the sand we're
going to be waiting about 1.6 billion
years here on Earth for him to go and
get these stars but Maul is traveling
super fast so time ticks differently for
him because of Relativity we talked
about this with Usain Bolt before if you
remember Brady right well mole is going
a lot faster than Usain bolts he's going
very very just just shy of the speed of
light because of the way of time time
changes at speed four mole he would
actually complete this journey in like I
said two years four months which is
which is just within his lifetime which
is pretty cool and actually so going at
that speed by the way I sort of
calculated how long mole would consider
himself as taking to go to Alpha
Centauri our nearest star system and
that would be about 0.3 seconds he would
do it about 0.3 seconds so yeah going
pretty fast but doable
I thought it was quite interesting okay
okay you should carry on carry on right
what does mole do okay so he's brought
these home so that night his borrow was
full of shimmering Starlight
so you see what bowl has done now so let
me all the carry on reading so mole
loved his bright new home so much so he
wanted to stay there forever now mole is
probably going to get what he wishes for
here quite frankly uh because now what
mole appears to have done here is get
the Stars
and shove him into his burrow
okay that's a lot of mass in a very
small space right so typical borough of
a mole right well okay it's about five
centimeters sort of wide about four
centimeters high and it can be up to
about 70 meters long actually
it's still not very big volume it's it's
still you know only about 0.14 of a
cubic meter it's not it's not a big
volume
but how much how what's the mass of the
stars that he's trying to shove into
this this Borough okay well I go back to
my little database I had to um I had to
actually calculate the
the master these of these Stars based on
on the luminosity and all that sort of
stuff
so I got an S there's a bit of an
estimate to be fair but I think it's
pretty accurate it won't be miles off
and I reckon these Stars these 5 000
stars or so that we've got their total
mass is about 20
175 times the mass of the Sun it sounds
reasonable actually it's not it doesn't
sound like a crazy number given that you
know you've got about five thousand of
them so it's about twenty thousand times
the mass of the Sun so this is how much
mass mold is trying to get into his
borrow well
okay suppose you try to cram that much
mass into a smaller space possible
how small is it going to be before it
collapses into a black hole you
calculate something called the Schwartz
style radius which is the size of the
Event Horizon of a mass that big
and for this much mass the schwarzstall
radius is about 59 000 kilometers so
that means you cannot cram this amount
of mass into a space less than 59 less
than roughly 59 000 kilometers in in
radius you just can't
otherwise it's going to turn into a
black hole so not only can mole not get
this into into his borrow or if he does
he's going to start turning his borrow
into a black hole he's actually going to
turn the earth into a black hole right
because the Earth is only about 6 000
kilometers in radius rate so kind of
cram all this stuff into into you know a
small region in around the air
eventually you're going to start
creating a black hole it's going to
swallow the whole air so that's pretty
Pretty Reckless Behavior by more like I
would say uh so you couldn't even fit
all these Stars into the Earth no no the
best you can do is create a black hole
which is about which is about sort of 10
times the size of the Earth that's the
best you could do that's mole's best
tactic
so yeah so that's so what's gonna happen
next mole so he wanted to stay there
forever
right well let's think about this
in his black hole he's not a black hole
so maybe he's gonna stay there forever
but actually not necessarily okay he's
in this black hole now is he going to
stay there forever no because remember
black holes radiate they give off a type
of when you play quantum mechanics to
the edge of a black hole you realize
that they're not as black as they seem
to give up this radiation which is named
after Stephen Hawking so they give off
Hawking radiation
so there is a time it takes for this
black hole to evaporate okay it's quite
a long time though right so this black
hole is going to take about 10 to the 80
years to evaporate 10 to the 80 that's a
familiar number it's a number of
particles in the universe that's why
you're over it but that's a tell
coincidence it's just it's just this the
complete coincidence but yeah so it's
about 10 to the 80 years for this black
hole to evaporate so Moe could get out
of this black hole that he's created
rather recklessly in 10 to the 80 years
however he's not going to get out as a
mole he's likely going to come out as
just Hawking radiation it's not great
but as the days went by he started to
miss his favorite Rock so one evening he
popped his head out of his molehill and
saw nothing the sky was dark well it's
not really a surprise is it because
you're created enough like oh and also
he's not getting out
actually so I I also wondered like what
so we say he could get out of the black
hole after 10 to the 80 years as Hawking
radiation what's the universe going to
look like then that stage of the
universe very far future we're talking
about and the universe is going to be
black hole dominated then there's going
to be an error between 10 to the 40 and
basically Google years when the universe
is just dominated by black holes all the
stuff has fallen into black holes some
of the black holes will be radiate will
have radiated away the smaller ones will
have done larger ones will still be
radiating but the universe is going to
be black hole dominated so actually the
sky it's going to be pretty black right
because there's going to be no star
shouting they've all been spotted by
black holes yeah well we we carry on so
deer stood in the clearing With Tears In
Her Eyes where are all the stars you
said failed Mouse field mouse is not
happy by the way feared Mouse shook his
head sadly my children love to stargaze
while I sing their bedtime lullaby they
will be so sad like moles feeling guilty
the Stars help me find my way said folks
where can they be side bear I have flown
far and high said Al the stars are gone
so I presume that owl is saying that
that she's flown 786 million light years
which seems a bit of an exaggeration but
we'll move on from that mole felt
terrible he didn't know the other
animals loved the stars as much as he
did he scurried into the trees hiding
himself away mole walked deeper and
deeper into the forest what had he done
their mold saw something glinting
through the trees a star laying a puddle
its light faded and dull could it be his
special shooting star
Mall Bank close oh how I wish I had
never taken the Stars he whispered
I didn't whisper that did I
the Stars began to twinkle and ladders
appeared I said ladders are back so he
must have had to go somewhere else for
the rest of the ladders now because he's
used up all the carbon on Earth for his
original satellite is mold didn't think
twice he rushed back to the clearing the
star lighting his way I'm sorry he cried
I took the Stars I wanted them for
myself but now I know the Stars belong
to everyone I'm going to put them back
okay so I think this is where we have to
start thinking about this again now
right so we've already established he's
created a black hole and that black hole
is going to get take 10 to the 80 years
to evaporate okay so modeling getting
out for a long time and when he does get
out the universe is now going to be
black hole dominated with barely any
stars in it at all all the stars are
swallowed by black holes
okay now those black holes will
evaporate themselves after about a
Google years so there's nothing really
to see the universe is just a dull and
boring place of Hawking radiation just
cold and miserable and it's a heat death
of the universe essentially if Moe
really wants to bring the stars back and
wants to be able to look up at the sky
again and see the stars I think he's
going to have to wait for a point career
recurrence
I think that's the only option whenever
you have a finite system you always get
back to where you started from so so for
example I take a pack of cards so
there's a finite number of arrangements
for a pack of cards if I shuffle the
cards enough I'll eventually get back to
the original order of the cards it'll
take many many many shuffles but I will
get there and it's the same you think
about gases in a room so you put all the
gases in the corner of a room and they
move around and there's this random
movement of the of the gas particles
eventually
after a very very long time they will at
some point end up back in the far corner
of the room that will happen Okay so you
always get this with this recurrence in
a finite system and we do believe our
universe is a finite system it's to do
we do we know this because we can look
at the entropy of our universe we
understand that it's finite and we think
it's finite and so therefore it's a
finite system
and so it has a point array recurrence
where it will get back to any initial
point okay so if it will wants to get
back to his starting point which is the
stars there which is the only way I
think he can do it he's gonna have to
wait wait for it I think this is
exceeding a moral Lifetime by the way 10
to the 10 to the 122 years
to 10 to the 10 to the 122 years so an
astonishingly long time that's the order
of magnitude that mole's gonna have to
wait before he gets his stars back and
you know he makes up for his his error
yeah long time most uh most uh bit
flawed a bit flawed yeah but not
entirely the ladders were fine right the
ladders
he is a fiendish puzzle from the clever
people at Jane Street custom made for
today's video you have to place two and
only two stars in each row column and
section of this grid no two stars can
directly neighbor each other either even
diagonally
if you can crack it the Stars will then
Mark out the letters to solve this
riddle what would happen if mold didn't
put all the stars back in the galaxy
I'll put a link to the puzzle below this
video so you can click straight through
to it
and while you're on the Jane Street
website why not check out the amazing
opportunities they have to work with
them in offices all around the world our
thanks to Jane Street for sharing our
love for impossibly big numbers puzzles
and reaching for the Stars
[Music]
let me ask you one more question if
people really enjoy big big numbers and
they enjoy books what book should they
buy oh well they actually right
fantastic numbers and a way to find them
um which can say which in my book you've
written a book about big numbers
you kept that secret yeah I don't tell
anybody about it yeah it's got all the
numbers all your favorite numbers in
Brady it's got like a Google a
googolplex it's got Graham's number and
tree three it's all our favorites it's
got some small numbers as well I know it
was released in the UK it's a real pity
it hasn't been released in America no it
has been released in America ready
I'm in America is that everywhere oh wow
you can go it doesn't look like this in
America looks a bit different but um
it's still there and it's the same name
fantastic numbers yeah you can get it in
a get it online or you can get it in you
know Barnes and Noble for example those
sorts of places I wonder if there will
be a link in the video description